to many Westerners Asia has more than
its share of suspicious-looking foods
but it's a good bet that there's nothing
as popular while at the same time as
utterly shocking to outsiders as a food
sold by street vendors in the
Philippines called balut could you eat
the fetus of a duck just days from
hatching almost every culture eats eggs
but balut is something different it's
fertilized so inside each creamy
soft-boiled Center is a prize a tiny
duck embryo with eyes a beak even
feathers almost complete enough to
plaque face read it good in the
Philippines balut is a national passion
as popular and as cheap as hot dogs in
the u.s. seasoned with vinegar it's
often savored to fear or brandy which
seems to make the slimy mess go down
easier
but there is something more powerful
than taste drawing people to this food
too many Filipinos balut is an
aphrodisiac
a potion they call the Philippine viagra
margarita Holmes is a psychologist and
popular sex columnist in the Philippines
so she says from childhood until now we
have absolute faith in this product that
we've been using it and it seems to work
all the time so I guess that means I
should try 120 bungu billion Wow
actually strictly speaking it's not
really an aphrodisiac because what
aphrodesia implies is that it increases
sexual desire and what men Filipino men
I think think of balut mainly is as it's
called in Filipino combat accustomed to
hood which is it it strengthens your
knees in other words it you know gives
you endurance and strength and all that
I had 16 children and five wives because
of the balloon it's good for sex
yeah that's Filipino yeah it's part of
our culture it's part of our myth but it
is an acquisition the self-fulfilling
prophecy has been found to be very
powerful and if it works why not
balut has plenty of believers like this
street vendor who always saves his last
balloon for himself I
so delicious